Is there danger with doing biopsies only they said they would be small needles
Well, there's danger of doing anything, but is that less invasive obviously they're going to surgically removing it to test it
Oh, I guess it was all nice and clean. Well now that we surgically removed it you can't put it back so
Yeah, it'd be much less invasive
You know you're talking about your invasiveness. What is doing nothing and what is
Next is doing nothing, but getting it tested on a regular basis the next would be
Maybe doing a biopsy and going from there. So
I know these are these are tough decisions when you know you're pushed in one direction, so
And you feel a lot of pressure in your decision making process, but you're just gonna stand your girl to go
Okay, want to be wise about this and and try to make the best decision. I'm not gonna just follow one person's advice